right since March of last year I have
been warning you the American people
about five forces that are working to
destroy President Trump yeah
partisan deep state bureaucrats we
learned a lot about them in the last
year and a half
Liberal Democrats your corrupt pathetic
media weak establishment Republicans and
this group called never Trump Rah's
yesterday what we have been telling you
for more than a year is now playing out
as we have predicted led by Robert
Muller's merry band a Democratic donors
and witch hunters the deep state has
successfully down targeted several Trump
associates they never would have been
targeted if they weren't friends with
the president and yesterday Paul
Manafort he was convicted of on 8 of 18
bank and tax fraud charges nothing to do
with Russia collusion and during an
exclusive interview that will air
tomorrow morning on Fox and Friends
President Trump
weighed in on that and so much more
let's get a sneak peek
are you considering pardoning Paul
Manafort I have great respect for what
he's done in terms of what he's gone
through you know you worked for Ronald
Reagan for years he worked for Bob Dole
he worked I guess his firm worked for
McCain he worked for many many people
many many years and I would say what he
did some of the charges they threw
against him every consultant every
lobbyist in Washington probably does if
you look at Hillary Clinton's person you
take a look at the people that work for
Hillary Clinton I mean look at the
crimes that Clinton did with the emails
and she deletes 33,000 emails after she
gets a subpoena from Congress and and
this Justice Department does nothing
about it and all of the other crimes
that they've done we're gonna have a lot
more on the blatant legal double
standard in a moment but first also
yesterday federal prosecutors compelled
Michael Cohen to plead guilty to bank
and tax fraud charges and some phony
campaign finance violations again none
of these charges have anything to do
with Russia Russia collusion President
Trump of the election of 2016 and last
night right here on this program the
great one Mark Levin completely debunked
the campaign related charges let's take
a look
general counsel for the crank Clinton
mob family lanny davis he had his client
plead the two counts of criminality that
don't exist these campaign finance
violations that all over TV they're
saying implicates the president the
United States directly first let's back
up
it is a guilty plea it is a plea bargain
between a prosecutor and a criminal a
criminal who doesn't want to spend the
rest of his life in prison
that is not precedent that applies only
to that specific case nobody cites plea
bargains for precedent that's number one
number two just because a prosecutor
says that somebody violated a campaign
law doesn't make it so he's not the
judge he's not the jury
we didn't adjudicate anything it never
went to court that's number two a
campaign expenditure under our federal
campaign laws is an expenditure solely
for campaign activity a candidate who
spends his own money or even corporate
money for an event that occurred not as
a result of the campaign it is not a
campaign expenditure in other words most
of the liberal lawyers you see on TV are
dopes they don't know the law look at
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
also debunking these charges guys watch
listen learn help you the law is clear
that a president may contribute to his
own campaign so if the president had
paid two hundred eighty thousand dollars
to these two women even if he had done
so in order to help his campaign that
would be no problem that's legal and if
Cohen himself made the contribution that
would be unlawful because he has a limit
of $5,200
so the complicated issue is what if
Trump told him to do it as Cohen says
then Cohen would be acting for Trump as
Trump's representative and the campaign
contribution would be lawful as long as
the president ultimately paid for it
that's the hundred percent right that's
the law and during an interview with
Ainsley Earhardt again she's gonna join
us in a few minutes the president
these payments were in no way a campaign
finance violation look at the law
take a look listen learn did you know
about the payments later on I knew later
on but you have to understand anything
what he did and they weren't taken out
of campaign finance that's a big thing
that's a much bigger thing did they come
out of the campaign they didn't come out
of the campaign they came from me and I
tweeted about it you know I put I don't
know if you know but I tweeted about the
payments but they didn't come out of
campaign in fact my first question when
I heard about it was did they come out
of the campaign because that could be a
little dicey and they didn't come out of
the campaign and that's big but they
weren't that's not a it's not even a
campaign violation if you look at
President Obama he had a massive
campaign violation but he had a
different Attorney General and they
viewed it a lot different now all the
media they want you to believe that
Michael Kohn he was a central player in
all things Trump the president well he
had a much different take let's listen
to him Michael Cohen tell me about your
relationship with him well he was a
lawyer for me for one of many you know
they they would say the lawyer and then
they'd like to add the fixer well I
don't know if it was a fixer I don't
know where that term came from but he's
been a lawyer from me didn't do big
deals did small deals not somebody that
was with me that much you know they make
it sound like I didn't live with without
him I understood Michael cone very well
he what turned out he wasn't a very good
lawyer frankly but he was somebody that
was probably with me for about ten years
and I would see him sometimes
now Michael Collins attorney lanny davis
said that his client would not even
accept a pardon from the president
actually said that today Lanny I've
known you a lot of years who are you
representing here that Michael cone
wouldn't accept a pardon he's facing as
many as five years in jail look Lanny I
know your soul embedded into the
Clintons and you love all things Clinton
but you're supposed to represent Michael
here and if he was ever offered a part
it'd be pretty stupid not to take it
what a disservice now no person would be
better off spending years in prison
with the felony conviction on their
track record or getting a pardon basic
simple common sense Lanny regardless of
what you think about Michael comb Paul
Manafort it is clear they have been
targeted they have been singled out for
their one-time connection to President
Trump and now both men and then you can
add Michael Flynn and George papadopolis
they all face time in jail a horrible
example of what we have been exposing on
this program a two-tiered justice system
equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws that's the great
system of our constitutional republic in
2008 you may recall the Obama campaign
they kept 1.3 million dollars in illegal
contributions guess what nobody got
charged nobody got indicted nobody went
to prison no one was slapped with a
felony just a campaign wide fine 375
grand 2017 the Clinton campaign the DNC
they were reported to the FEC for
failing to properly disclose their
financial contributions to the dirty
dossier you know that was funneled to
Perkins Cooley the law firm had then
hired oh fusion GPS the OP research
group that then hired Christopher Steele
the foreign national is not supposed to
impact our elections that then paid for
Russian lies that he doesn't even stand
by then became the basis to lie to the
American people before the campaign then
became the basis of four FISA warrants
to spy on a trump campaign associate
that's the whole thing they didn't
report that money that he paid all
that's what legal expense it wasn't
robert muller nowhere to be found and on
the tax front and 2015 according to a
report from then congressman jason
Chaffetz he's in for Laura Ingraham
tonight federal workers owed a billion
dollars in unpaid taxes that's right
they worked for your government
including many in Obama's White House of
course no special counsel no
investigation no indictment nothing
against these tax cheats remember tax
cheat tightener they were working in our
federal government a lot billion dollars
the kind of a lot of money I read that
somewhere it's now really clear that
there's one system of justice
for Hillary Clinton the Democrats deep
state bureaucrats the Obama White House
they have one system of justice anyone
else you and me
anyone tied to Donald Trump a different
system of Justice this Republic can
survive with a dual justice system which
brings us to our next critical point I
have been shouting this from the
rooftops since May we are about to face
what I'm calling the most important
midterm elections in our lifetime 76
days from today while the deep state is
working around the clock to dig up dirt
on anybody anything associated with this
president that you elected the American
people Democrats are now planning to use
this information to bring articles of
impeachment against the president it
doesn't matter that there's no collusion
mark levin was right last night robert
muller will write an impeachment
document it doesn't matter that the
president did nothing wrong and broke no
law mark my words if democrats if you
stay home on Election Day and Democrats
take back the House of Representatives I
promise you mark my words they will
bring articles of impeachment against
the president I have been warning about
this for a long time if you don't
believe it now I don't know what will
make you believe it 76 days you will
decide if the president and his agenda
goes forward because they will stop that
there's November the future of this
continued successful economic boom
continued peace through strength all of
this a lot of there's a lot of stuff at
stake and sadly that's not all we know
what the Democratic agenda is is pretty
scary actually let's see what they
called crumbs your tax cuts they want
their crumbs back and as we said they
want to impeach the president as we've
told you they want to preserve Obamacare
lose your doctor lose your plan pay more
that seems to work for them they want to
block judge Cavanaugh and
constitutionalist to the Supreme Court
originalist they want open borders they
want to eliminate ice they're saying as
much they want to kill off all of these
investigations just drop it right there
for their deep state friends and this
massive abuse of power that we have been
able to expose and as always the
mainstream media to destroy Trump media
they're just doing the bidding of the
left the Democratic Party they're an
extension of their press office and like
a broken record you know what seems like
the millionth time the crisis peddlers
in the news media in this country the
echo chamber they're all predicting the
same thing because it's what they're
hoping for impeachment this is what they
wanted for a long time this is their
shot take a look
given the events of today the likelihood
of impeachment I'm not saying it's high
necessarily but it certainly went up
impeachment impeachment impeachment
pete-r and impeach impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment the
president's clearly guilty of high
crimes and misdemeanors he should resign
his office or be impeached today the
trump presidency took a giant step
toward impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
implications are now in the air
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment if it is a crime it
certainly is an impeachable offense
impeach Trump impeachment impeachment
remember [ __ ] that's all that's all
remember stormy stormy stormy Russia
Russia Russia they hyperventilate over
whatever the issue is of the day for
over 24 hours
your apocalyptic press have been working
overtime in overdrive pushing anti-trump
conspiracy theory after conspiracy
theory we have the evidence
take a look you decide the man who once
said he'd take a bullet for Donald Trump
today in federal court was essentially
calling his old boss and clients now the
president United States a crook so there
are a lot of players now who start to
potentially construct an enterprise a
criminal enterprise that is around or
may even involve the president it's very
baked in as of now and is not going to
change that Donald Trump is indeed a
scumbag voters know that I just I I
think there is something worse than a
useful idiot and that would be a useful
idiot under legal siege and that is what
President Donald Trump is this morning
we really want to stay home in 76 days
if you vote for the president happy with
the economy you want to stay the course
you like the judges appointed you want
borders secured do you want health care
transformed do you want peace through
strength but it's this kind of
breathless abusive bias it's the very
reason the president has rightly
criticized the media including this
moment in his interview on Fox and
Friends little air tomorrow morning with
Ainsley take a look the press is the
press the enemy of the people no not at
all but the fake news is and the fake
news is comprised of it's a lot it's a
big chunk okay somebody said what's the
chunk I said 80% it's a lot it's a lot
if I do something well it's not reported
other than in the 20% I mean the New
York Times cannot write a good story
about me they're crazed they're like
lunatics as you can see from tonight's
monologue I told you a long time ago
very beginning it actually started the
day he and Melania came down the
escalator five forces that have been
working against the president they're
now more active they they sense there's
blood in the water
they are literally harmoniously working
together and yeah most of them would
love the impeachment of the president
you voted for and stop the progress ruin
his agenda now this is real
and never and as it as it been more
important if you care about your vote in
2016 you might want to register and vote
knowing that this hate this destruction
this havoc that will occur if the
Democrats take back the house it's a
clear and present danger so don't tell
me by the way the morning after the
election that you didn't have sufficient
knowledge of what they would do 76 days
from today you have a massive
opportunity to protect your vote in 2016
preserve that vote repair the system of
justice make this country a better place
for every American there's a lot riding
on this midterm they want to undo the
agenda you voted for they want to stop
the progress we have obviously made that
they'll never talk about in the media
all right before we wrap up our
monologue tonight let's turn to this
horrific sad story out of Iowa 20-year
old college student Molly Tibbets
senselessly murdered her body recovered
in a cornfield and now a Mexican
national in this country illegally has
now confessed to stalking and murdering
Molly Tibbets while she was out jogging
the monster likely responsible for this
crime is now being held on five million
dollars in bail earlier today the
president he reacted on Twitter take a
look Molly Tibbets an incredible young
woman is now permanently separated from
her family a person came in from Mexico
illegally and killed her
we need the wall we need our immigration
laws changed
we need our boarder laws changed we need
Republicans to do it because the
Democrats aren't going to do it to the
family of Molly Tibbets all I can say is
God bless you Fox News comm has been
covering this tragic story for weeks